لا أعلم أنني ما زلت أشعر بالخدر
بدأ في الغرق الآن ولكن ليس
بطريقة جيدة ستورمي دانيلز في
أول مقابلة لها منذ
لائحة الاتهام ضد دونالد ترامب تخبر الأوقات في المملكة المتحدة أن هذا هو
إثبات أعلم أنني أحصل عليه في هذه
اللحظات  حيث أشعر بالعاطفة ، كما لو أنني
أتمنى لو لم أفعل هذا مطلقًا ، هذا
غبي جدًا ، لكنني ما زلت أفعل نفس الشيء
لأنه كان من الصواب القيام بذلك ، إنه
قرار قانوني استغرق
صنعه سنوات منذ أول انفجار لدانيال  في دائرة
الضوء العامة ،
عُرفت باسم الممثلة السينمائية البالغة
المرتبطة بالرئيس السابق لكنها
ولدت ستيفاني كليفورد كتبت في
سيرتها الذاتية عن طفولة في باتون
روج لويزيانا التي أهملتها
والدتها الوحيدة التي تركتها وحدها دون طعام.
رجل عاش بجوار صديق كنت في
التاسعة من عمري ، كنت طفلاً ، ثم لم أكن
طريقاً للخروج من الفقر ، كان
التجريد أولاً ثم المواد الإباحية
ثم أصبحت ستورمي دانيلز كممثلة بالغة ، ثم كانت مخرجة في عام 2006 ،
كانت دانيلز في بحيرة تاهو  تروج كاليفورنيا
لشركة أفلام الكبار الخاصة بها في إحدى
بطولات الجولف الشهيرة حيث قابلت دونالد
ترامب وتقول إنها مارست الجنس بالتراضي
معه ، ونفى ترامب باستمرار
هذه العلاقة
بسرعة حتى أكتوبر 2016. دونالد
ترامب هو مرشح جمهوري لتقديم
تقارير الرئيس
والمحاكمة الفيدرالية  من المحامي الشخصي الرابح آنذاك
مايكل كوهين ، سمح المديرون التنفيذيون في منظمة ترامب
للمدفوعات قبل أيام من
انتخابات عام 2016 لتغطية
دفعة كوهين البالغة 130 ألفًا إلى ستورمي
دانيلز بهدف إسكاتها عن الإعلان
عن القضية المزعومة ،
لكن دانيلز حاولت بالفعل سرد
قصتها في  وافقت دانيلز في عام 2011 على التحدث
إلى مجلة التابلويد في اتصال مقابل خمسة عشر
ألف دولار ، لم تتم
طباعة القصة في عام 2011. ولكن في عام 2018 ،
أعلنت دانيلز عن القصة التي أصبحت الآن
مشهدًا كان نجم تلفزيون الواقع السابق ترامب
رئيسًا للولايات المتحدة.
أنا والمحامية ملتزمون
بالتأكد من أن الجميع يكتشفون
الحقيقة وحقائق ما حدث ، مما
يضعها في وسط
عاصفة إعلامية وثقافية وثقافية شعبية ، مرحبًا
دونالد ، تواصل دانيلز اليوم
مسيرتها المهنية في مجال الأفلام للبالغين وتظل خاصة بشأن
ابنتها وأثناء  هناك
حفر عرضي على ترامب على حساباتها على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ،
تجنبت دانيلز
الحديث مباشرة عن هذه القضية ، لكن الآن بعد أن
كشفت لائحة الاتهام التاريخية هذه ،
تخبر دانيلز مرات في المملكة المتحدة أن سلامتها في خطر أكثر
من أي
وقت مضى في المرة الأولى التي كنت فيها مثل الفاسقات المنقبين عن الذهب.
أنت تعرف الكاذب أيا كان ، وهذه المرة يبدو الأمر
كما لو أنني سأقتلك